excellent schon instant leute am start hier ging er zackig das twitch
kopierte dass das stream on ist das dauert ja manchmal bis zu 10 minuten
teilweise wer ist er da zeig mal her der twitch zuschauer zuschauer
das sind natürlich augen das erkenne ich auch ich bin ich gar so sehr boomer
bin ich auch nicht durch das erkenne gpad 1 hd ist da der sick bär 45 chill im eck
der hook wolle 1508 und matze 90 zwar 20 90 so rum
matzel plays abonniert drei monate exzellent huge subscription
dankeschön der schäger ist auch da ja also was wir heute ausprobieren programmieren
nicht weiter wir probieren mal was anderes aus ich finde das das habe ich
auf reddit gesehen das sah wirklich nicht schlecht aus und zwar das hier habe ich
vorher noch nichts wirklich noch gar nichts davon gehört habe ich habe ich
auf auf ich mache mal ich mach mal kurz das bild weg habe ich noch nichts davor
gesehen habe ich heute morgen auf reddit gelesen
und zwar ist das wohl eine was sagen sie denn also das ist irgendein web
interface aufsatz wo man sich auf knopfdruck linux system erzeugen kann
die also gut linux system erzeugen kann die komplett im browser laufen und da
gibt es dann beispielsweise vorkonfigurierte sachen mit dem xfce
desktop mit dem tor browser mit dem chrome mit dem firefox und sonst was
also man kann sich quasi auf click wegwerf linux system erzeugen das ist
eigentlich eine ganz coole idee wenn man mal was ausprobieren will und danach den
ganzen kram sicher gelöscht haben will ist das eigentlich eine coole sache so
wie es aussieht läuft es nicht auf dem raspberry pi oder noch nicht es gibt ein
paar docker arm images aber die sind wohl nicht lauffähig das ist blöd
gerade wenn so was auf raspberry laufen würde natürlich besonders pro also so
was wie rdp über browser so ja so ungefähr stelle ich mir das vor so was
wie rdp über browser und mit der mit der möglichkeit dass man halt die dass die
sachen direkt gelöscht werden wenn man recession zu macht so ungefähr stelle ich
mir vor wie gesagt ich habe mir nur vorhin mal das install video angeguckt
das haben wirklich easy as fuck aus kostet auch nix das ganze
warte mal hier support documentation die haben so ein install video das ist
wirklich echt einfach wir gucken uns jetzt nicht an also man man downloaden
den ihr tage z geht auf eine kiste installiert den kram und dann läuft so
so sieht es dann am ende aus da kann man sich verschiedene images auswählen was
man haben will also sprich in firefox den desktop den tor browser gibt es auch
irgendwo habe ich gesehen und wenn man das schließt
speicherte die sachen und wenn man auf lockout drückt löschte die sachen
irgendwie das klingt nicht verkehrt inwieweit es jetzt besser ist als ein
lilox system in der vm was man wegschmeißen kann sei mal dahin
gestellt aber es ist auf jeden fall schneller wenn man einfach mal einen
browser will der definitiv nicht windows ist was natürlich noch besonders cool
wäre wenn es das mal demnächst eventuell von
raspberry pi gibt weil man macht es mal kurz aus wenn es es von raspberry pi
gibt wäre man ja auch automatisch immun gegen spektrum meltdown und was es nicht
so gibt alles nicht dass es großartig was ausmacht aber so wirklich 100 prozentig
sicher kann es dir ja nie sein das probieren jetzt mal aus mal gucken das
kann total schnell gehen dass es in einer halben stunde funktioniert oder es ist
obelis das rumgefrickelt also das ist der installer an sich also das war das
video ich habe mir vorhin anguckt das ist wirklich einfach also im prinzip
braucht man nur irgendeinen debian ab 9 in ubuntu ab 1804 oder einen oder ein
nicht sogar ubuntu ab 16 04 und cento s ab 7 und debian ab 9 also theoretisch
wird es auf raspberry pi laufen leider gibt es keine arm images was schon ein
bisschen doof ist deswegen glaube dass ich so raspberry pi 4 wäre dafür halt
richtig praktisch wäre ich nicht würde dann würde ich gut funktionieren und
und man bräuchte da halt nicht nichts anderes in dem fall bei mir ist kein
problem ich habe eben eine x86 low power kiste hier neben laufen also das mit
so einem low end mainboard drin da läuft es auf jeden fall drauf ja das heißt
wir können jetzt die recycle die vm recycle vorgestern schon so früh von der
arbeit daheim nee ich habe auch nicht gearbeitet
exzellent wir können wir können die deep in vm recycle die rename wir jetzt mal
kann man das remain rename rename kassen kray gasm die festplatte können wir
gebrauchen da brauchen wir jetzt noch den ubuntu image ein aktuelles
ubuntu server download wir nehmen einfach in 2004 und dann probieren wir das
probieren wir das mal aus gucken wir mal wie gut das funktioniert jetzt sagen wir
mal bitte was immer soll mit der eins löschen hier guck mal exzellent soll
das das hier so damit ich mich nicht wiederholen muss weil die frage total
oft kommt gucken wir uns jetzt live gucken wir uns jetzt mal live im stream
an was ich dazu gesagt habe ich weiß es nämlich selbst nicht mehr was ich dazu
gesagt habe ich weiß nur so ungefähr noch so und dann kratte
ups dann auskratte oder auch was ich ganz gerne machen etwas rechts anklicken
und dann auf copy und so das ist einfach einfach tick von mir das ist so hier so
was in der richtung das hat nichts nichts nichts zu sagen ja und ich glaube das
liegt daran weil ich mir das zur zeit angewöhnt habe wo man auch viel
icq textnachrichten geschickt hat und ich habe sehr viel icq textnachrichten
immer immer teile von copy pasted wenn man also Sachen die sich wiederholt haben
und so die man und da hatte ich immer schiss dass ich aus versehen cool story
max falschen wie auch immer dann außerdem die falsche nachricht schicke was
weiß ich wenn ich über einen geflamed habe wollte ich dem das nicht gerade schicken
deswegen habe ich mir angewöhnt mein clipboard irgendwie leer zu machen ja
deswegen genau ja so sieht es aus ich habe früher quasi vor slack und teams
also wo man auch schon instant messenger benutzt hat habe ich immer mein clipboard
leer gemacht dass ich nicht aus versehen copy paste an den falschen irgendwas
schicke wahrscheinlich wäre es nie passiert aber ich habe mir das dann
angewöhnt deswegen mache ich jetzt die ganze zeit hier meine einser und kopier
teams größer icq change war mein sehbar ich glaube es gibt niemand der
dann ein mein changen will
hättest du jetzt gesagt teams größer icq größer teams ja da könnte man sich
drüber streiten ich zeige euch was ich habe was ich habe was neues
was mal auf ich hoffe ich hoffe ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt muss nur
gucken dass der ich will nicht das schiener lilo starten gehe weg
ich will network gut machen guck mal hier passt mal auf network boot ob obacht
network boot das sollte eigentlich funktionieren
auch funktionieren das net
warum warum was
um geht warum ging das jetzt net
eigentlich sollte ein px e boot machen jetzt steht das hier auf
ich bin warum hatten er kein px e boot jetzt gemacht
ja na klar das geht ja gar nicht das ist die falsche falsche interface
lull das ist das falsche network interface ja da jetzt ist ja auch klar
warum es funktioniert so achtung wir stellen es jetzt um network jaja kein
kein schiener lilox stellen um zack network interface bricht ja wenn ich das
falsche network das ist klar dass es nicht funktioniert so jetzt aber da
brauchst ja mehr reactions an den cs also ist ja jetzt kommt so so jetzt aber achtung postchamp
jetzt macht der px e boot kaum hat man das richtige hinterfasetrainer klappt
das auch
ich habe mir heute morgen nämlich gedacht in letzter zeit bin ich so oft am
ubuntu sonst war es neue vms irgendwie kram installieren warum machst du nicht
mal wieder px e server und ich habe da ein ziemlich cooles fertiges image für
gefunden war jetzt erst mal bis er gebootet hat da kann ich euch zeigen was
der was der jetzt anbietet normalerweise ist der schneller nicht dass er jetzt
irgendwie hängt oder so
hier guck mal was man alles auswählen kann also das ist das ist die das ist das
boot von netboot x y z hat sozusagen lokalbooten von dings du kannst linux
network installs auswählen ihr seht schon alles mögliche also alles
wichtige dabei von debian bis irgendwelche ip fire geschichten open
suze nixos ubuntu alles mögliche bei auch so komisches zeug wie tiny core
rancher os was glaube ich kein mensch mehr verwendet red hat ist montana
linux dabei nein ist nicht dabei
nein nein ist nicht dabei oder ist das nein das glaube ich nicht
eher nicht so man kann live cd starten da ist da ist wirklich ziemlich
ziemlich viel kram drinne als man mal irgendwas recovery braucht für die
hacker unter uns kann man jetzt einfach kann man kali starten dann dass die
ganzen hacker mensch sich mal freuen
so und das coole ist dass das halt alles geht ohne dass man sich isos vorher
runterlädt kann ich an windows 10 ja kann es man kann sogar in windows windows
booten man braucht nur in den netzbergscheren mit einem packen iso das
jetzt aber nicht so das problem
so jetzt laden wir das aktuelle kali linux runter debian basis und dann ist
hacker ist hacker man angesagt wobei ehrlich gesagt starten wir dann gleich
wieder neu aber ich will euch bloß zeigen dass es prinzipiell funktioniert
das ist jetzt halt reines net boot ich muss vorher nichts runterladen aber
deswegen muss halt beim starten die wichtigen sachen downloaden
kock zack iso gezogen oder nicht iso gezogen in it gedöns gezogen und zack
eine runde kali booten der sollte jetzt so einen blauen desktop booten eigentlich
oder so ein dunkelblauen war das oder hellblauen ich kann mich da gar nicht
irgendein blauer desktop ist es oder war das nee warte mal war kali das silberne
oder das blaue sehen wir gleich ich glaube das war so blau
oh was macht er da ohje ah der leht der leht jetzt in debian live image
runde ok ich glaube die heckermans müssen noch kurz warten
ja wie dem auch sei wir lassen den mal weiter laden da zeige ich euch dass das
funktioniert wenn es ihnen da eh gleich eine punto drüber aber ich habe hier
einen super easy pxe server gefunden und zwar netboot das war das war was ist das
hier unten für einer war man die also den habe ich nicht wenn du mal kurz
gucken was es da sonst noch so gibt
und er hat hier die etwa anstre varianten windows 10 4 jahre lull ein ja also den
habe ich acht tage 8 days ago und man muss eigentlich nichts anderes machen
dass das funktioniert wie also entweder direkt über docker starten oder in sein
compose file eintragen und schon geht's also ich habe das mehr oder weniger
eins zu eins so in mein compose file eingetragen und gestartet und funktioniert
der cache die isis wenn er mal runter gelandert ne das macht das
standardmäßig nicht das macht er wahrscheinlich nur wenn man hier diese
diese asset geschichte konfiguriert hat die habe ich nicht drin
kann man bestimmt einstellen müssen wir mal gucken zumindest ist das ziemlich
easy einfach das ding in seinen compose file eintragen und zack funktioniert
zack px e boot easy so gut der mirror ist halt lahm as fuck ne guckt euch das mal
an also ja und die wichtigste sache die man machen muss danach muss man in sein
px e server gehen und die kiste hier eintragen als boot boot server dann aber
das war das könnten wir eigentlich auch mal im stream machen ich könnte wir
könnten mal im stream den px e server installieren das geht schnell
vielleicht machen wir das sogar heute noch mal demonstrationsweise das geht
schnell und ich weiß dass da viele leute straggeln mit px e server zu
installieren aber das liegt glaube ich daran weil die meisten leute versuchen
das mit irgendeinem komischen windauszeug hinzufuddeln und naja
die dhcp kann ich mein ex großartig was soll ich mir da zerhauen
das ist ja der gleiche dhcp server wie vorher und ich muss einfach der next
next server zum booten eintragen und mehr nicht boah nee okay kommen wir sind
jetzt wir warten wir warten jetzt mal noch die eineinhalb die eineinhalb
minuten warten wir jetzt noch bevor wir jetzt abbrechen genau wie gesagt den
kram installieren wir gleich so chat wir müssen jetzt noch eineinhalb minuten
warten oder eine minute warten dass wir hacksaw linux
gestartet haben backtrack war grün gelb oder rot das habe ich glaube ich noch
nie verwendet genau kali war kali war blau
genau das war das da stimm ich kann mich dran erinnern
ich habe eine empfehlung für dich was ssh oder rtp connection angeht schau dir
mal mom remote an sehr praktisch ok zeig mal ja
du meinst m remote wahrscheinlich im remote engie engie ist schon mal hier
nextlevel schon absolut alles was engie heißt muss big brain sein das war ja
mal eine zeit lang im trend dass viele open source projekte einfach engie
dran gemacht haben egal was es war irgend einer hat was gefolgt da war das
gleich engie also auch guck mal die haben für ordentlich viele ordentlich
viele stars auf github scheint schon mal relativ beliebt zu sein
k m remote engie ist in next generation of m remote open source tapped
multiprotocol remote connect ja was denn noch alles
gerne paar screenshots jetzt gibt es vor allem nicht das screenshots
augmentation
aha das ist ein gui das ist kein webinterface
wow das sieht aus wie monkaS das das ist windows only kann das sein
das wenn er uns auch nie
das sieht das sieht hardcore windows only aus ok ja und wofür braucht man das
ist das hnt schon mal nicht das ist quasi so eine art book markt remote
bookserver bookmark manager also sprich man kann sich quasi bookmarks machen auf
auf was weiß ich für ssh für vnc für rdp und dann startet es die passenden
programme wenn ich es anklecke ja ich glaube wenn man wenn das only ist ist
das gar nicht übel
oh nicht mehr so soll ich aktuell zu sein schau mal letzte kommets
letzte kommets sechs tage ok die haben bloß keinen bock mehr blog post zu
schreiben kann ich verstehen liest eh keiner gut aber da muss ich sagen dass
für mich ist jetzt nicht ich werde es nicht gebrauchen können weil ich
verwende ja in der regel kein windows für wenn ich ernsthafte sachen machen
muss und unsere links mache ich eigentlich quasi quasi nur ausschließlich
ssh und das mache ich übers terminal aber es gut dass solche sachen gibt was
auch den windows user ein bisschen das leben leichter macht also generell hast
es ja auch finde ich allgemein ein bisschen schwerer
was der zeigt die fenster die er sport innerhalb von m remote an gut dann sieht
das so aus als als würde wer das besser integriert ist nicht schlecht so hat es
jetzt runtergeladen oh wir kommen gerade rechtzeitig hexa linux
let's go
da sind wir eine runde eine runde kali hexa linux
display settings müssen wir kurz ein bisschen größer machen das hat
anscheinend keine vmw das hat anscheinend keine vmw tools dabei denke
ich war das hätte man machen können und was ich halt doof finde dass vmw
sich standardmäßig nicht mit 920 1080 meldet dass man immer so komische
jaja kiept schäden so eine komische schäbe auflösung verwenden muss ja exe
es läuft aber relativ flüssig ist es ist irgendwie gnome auf jeden fall
gegen den gnome ich wollte gerade sagen wir können ausprobieren wieviel hashes
pro sekunde ich generieren kann aber das bringt mir nix weil ich ja meine
grafikkarte gar nicht drin habe und ich habe auch komplett vergessen wie
dieses dieses tool zum hashes durchprobieren hieß
war das denn passwort attacks weil man in crack könnte es gewesen sein
kransch nk nk nee zwar dass der kranz ach ich kann mich ich weiß es nicht
haschkett haschkett haschkett ist das genau dass er bauer hat recht exzellent
da kann man jetzt durchprobieren wieviel erstes jenem gnome auf jeden fall
ruby
so jetzt sind die ganzen heck so hier am start deswegen geboten wir jetzt zu
viel zu viel hack china linux china geh weg geh weg china linux will kein china
linux ich will pxe bunt machen und ubuntu installieren geh weg china
so während das installiert gucken wir uns noch mal kurz hier die hilfeseite an
ja ach nee der ubuntu installer geht tatsächlich ziemlich schnell die sind
nicht groß die sind bloß irgendwie paar hundert keine ahnung 150 mb oder so dass
das ubuntu net install man das geht das gibt also ubuntu net install geht
wirklich schnell
das ist halt ultra praktisch na was hast du genau vor also wir installieren
jetzt das da und ich habe da ich habe das heute gelesen auf reddit damit kann
man angeblich sich auf auf maus klick frische win frische linux desktops
erstellen oder oder browser oder tor browser oder chrome firefox was auch
immer quasi frische linux container erstellen auf maus klick pro session
neu auch mit anonymisierungstools alles mögliche dabei wenn man was schnell
ausprobieren will macht man ein browser tab auf damit geht man hier drauf dann
hat man eine komplett neue session mit komplett neuem login komplett neu im
browser komplett neu im desktop kann ausprobieren und wenn man fertig ist kann
man wieder kamer wieder wegschmeißen und das alles über den browser mal gucken
ob das was taugt so language englisch territory germann ja ja über layout
yes yes wir haben nein wir sind wir sind das haben wir nicht da muss man ein land
weitergehen da gibt es das so eine weg weg weg weg werft desktop weg werft browser
ja no continue no dead keys genau das ist richtig so sieht es aus excellent ip
konfig netzwerk konfig das guck mal das ist jetzt eine komplette installation die
komplett aus aus dem netzwerk läuft also auch in dem fall halt übers internet
ohne dass wir von iso runterladen muss das ist doch wirklich sehr zackig gut er
macht ja auch grad noch nix ubuntu archief germany ist gut jawohl mal gucken
auf big fuck jetzt habe ich weggeschaltet
na das geht doch für das dass es ein netzwerk in netzwerk installation ist
installierst du gerade die ubuntu server version noch ist das der normale generic
ubuntu installer ich müsste jetzt irgendwann auswählen können was ich
haben will das kommt jetzt irgendwann ja weil die weil die installation ist ja
ist ja gleich zwischen ubuntu server und desktop bis halt welche welche pakete
installiert werden so test password 123456 123456 excellent
so usb was was was will der von mir seit wann ist 123456 schlecht das ist das
beste password das kann ich weak sein verwendet doch sonst keiner ich weiß noch
mein vater hat früher immer gesagt er hat auch so komische passwörter verwendet
hat immer gesagt ach das password ist so blöd da kommt keiner drauf
ich war auch der einzige der blöd ist das ist so einfach das probiert eh
keiner aus also das ist ja wirklich das war wirklich eines der bescheuertsten
begründungen aller zeiten der wollt der wollte sich einfach nichts
komplizierteres merken der hat aber auch bis heute nicht
verstanden dass es desktop heißt und nicht desko dann immer gesagt desko
ah jetzt jetzt lädt er sich den kram runter aber das müsste trotzdem relativ
schnell gehen ja der hat dann immer gesagt machst du
mir das also mach machst du mir auf desktop mach mir das mal auf desktop
dass ich weiß nicht ob er es absichtlich gesagt hat oder ob das
einfach aber dass er lustig fand irgendwann oder ob es bis bis heute
nicht gecheckt hat dass es desktop heißt und ich des koop des des des
koop könnte man noch aber richtig also wenn einer boomer ist dann ja ja ne ich
glaube nicht dass der mich ärgern wollte ich glaube der wollte der wusste das
wirklich nicht besser
übrigens gleich springt das von da nach da das ist gebadet guck hier huge
tibet der installer will dass man denkt es dauert jetzt ewig und dabei macht es
gleich quets 12345 das ist auch nicht schlecht
was sind die die meist was sind die meist verwendete password garantiert
sowas wie quets 123456 hallo und sowas password password 123 password ja
wahrscheinlich also wir haben sie auf der arbeit auch öfters davon dass leute
irgendwelche kackpasswörter haben und das liegt das liegt zum größten teil
daran glaube ich mal mit oder mit mit nicht zum größten halt erstens sind die
leute faul zweitens das ist das hauptsächliche punkt die leute können
sich das gar nicht merken großartig großartig lange passwörter und deswegen
gibt es ja so passwortrichtlinien und wir haben so eine ganz merkwürdige
passwortrichtlinie du musst irgendwie was weiß ich mindestens so und so viel
zeichen groß klein sonderzeichen zahlen das darf nicht fünfmal hintereinander
das gleiche kommen so als wir haben total abgedrehte passwortrichtlinien und
deswegen machen die leute jetzt die einfachsten sachen die passen die machen
dann sowas wie keine ahnung hallo 123 underscore hallo 123 und sowas machen die
weil weil das auf die passwortrichtlinien match automatic updates liegt
du kannst noch einer inzulix guck und schon ist der installer durch moment ich
müsste doch jetzt eigentlich auswählen können wann ich was ich installieren
will kommt es jetzt noch normalerweise fragt er dich im installer
ne ne hallo123 underscore hallo123 das reicht schon, du brauchst kein ausruf
ausrufzeichen mehr ach jetzt jetzt genau also was brauchen wir hier Ubuntu
basic server und ssh zack wunderbar jetzt kann er fertig installieren ja das
deswegen ich bin der mein so diese ultra passwortrichtlinien bringen gar
nichts weißt du wisst du also meiner meinung nach sollte man passwortrichtlinien
so machen man sollte sagen sagen wir 14 zeichen plus egal was die leute können
meinetwegen auch 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 30 40 was auch immer machen
wobei ne das sind ja dann 20 oder 18 oder so also das wäre mir auch egal
hauptsache lang hauptsache lang lang ist das wichtigste bei passwort
hauptsache lang der reste ist egal
wenn es 1 2 3 4 5 7 8 9 an 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ist also das ist natürlich kein
gutes passwort aber länge ist das entscheidende bei passwort haben das ist
auch so fangfrage die ich fast jedem neuen azubi stelle ja ständig pass wenn
das passwort aus wenn das passwort ordentlich lang ist muss man das auch
nicht all drei monate erinnern ich fragte ich fragte ja immer ja ok was
meinst du was was wichtiger ist passwort komplex also passwort länge oder passwort
komplexität noch kontakt zum friseur ja wir haben uns ich habe gerade vorher noch
mit dem friseur geschrieben direkt vorm stream so jetzt gut jetzt ist der kram
installiert ja ja mach utc glock da können wir uns jetzt auch drauf einloggen
das machen natürlich von der anderen vm ich mache das nicht über dieses install
fenster hier
ich sehe nichts vm wer nett hinweg ist next so reboot und dann gehen wir in die
andere vm und loggen uns da per ssh drauf ein 80 komplett verkehrt ja das mache
ich mittlerweile aber auch so ich zähle mein passwort auf der arbeit auch nur noch
hoch weil ich sehe es nicht ein auch alle irgendwie ein zwei monate den kram zu
ändern so was haben wir jetzt eigentlich für eine ip gekriegt zusammen für eine
ip 39 alles klar exzellent gut den kram von
gestern machen wir mal zu ah meine güte so viel c++ geht sofort so also ssh 122
1682 punkt 139 und zwar als user test yes 1 2 3 4 5 6
jawoll da sind wir sehr gut ab update machen wir noch mal update vorher
ja wie keine upgrade da seht ihr mal was das schöne ist bei einem net install
wir haben jetzt einfach net install gemacht und es ist alles instant aktuell
du machst meistens sudo minus s echt was der unterschied
also du minus ui ist interaktiv login scripts und was macht minus s 20 aus dem
kopf nicht so exzellent
der scher schell run the shell specified bei schellen war achso ja ne ich will
er log in scripts ausführen so ein schitter im zweifelsfall noch mal
username trennen den die sudo minus ist schon ist schon sinnvoll oder habe ich
das jetzt irgendwas falsch gesehen mit task cell kann es den desktop nach
den schweiß schweiß aber in dem fall komplett unnötig weil brauche nicht so
wo ist der installer zeigt mal her
die haben doch hier irgendein tutorial gehabt wo man documentation install
dann hat installation genau und den swap feit brauche man den swap feit ich habe
bestimmt genug haben wir hier ja guck mal 8 8 g ram und 2 g swap da kann man
nichts sagen das ist vollkommen in ordnung
das ist passt so weiter geht es erstmal downloaden den kram ok dann
downloaden wir es erstmal download und hier aber man kann es direkt hier
runterladen das schon mal ganz praktisch und es kommen keine captures und es
kommen keine redirects es ist teilweise so nervig wenn seiten
irgendeine download button haben und der download button ist nicht der download
sondern du kommst auf einer capture seite raus wurde da erst mal bilder
anklicken muss mit mit feuerhydrant oder mit gw oder ampeln oder lkw oder
fahrrädern oder feinster scheiben oder schaufenster oder captures gibt ja
gefühlt unendlich viele capture varianten und dann wirst du noch
redirected das heißt du kannst den kram nie richtig runterladen über die
konsole wobei warum eigentlich das ist alles gut
müssen das wahrscheinlich gar nicht gut machen
weget zack download ab geht's hentai captures wären geil ja sebaro dann
würde ich sagen muss man so was programmieren und das gibt es
bestimmt ja palmen sind auch sehr beliebt in captures genau es gibt
garant sebaro das gibt es garantiert das 100 pro 100 pro ich will es gibt alles
als captures das gibt es bestimmt auch aber wahrscheinlich nicht auf den
normalen seiten
so also okay wie geht es weiter
zd okay nach template wir machen wir machen das jetzt einfach mal was die
sagen nicht dass die irgendwie hardcoded fahnen oder so was haben so das ist ein
tag also sprich ta xfz v kassen bämen oder es ging aber schnell also groß ist
das nicht ja wie groß ist das 32 mb das ist ja nix
es ist wahrscheinlich ist es nur ein bisschen web frontend ohne was dabei
audio captures sind ganz besonders schlimm ja audio captures ist ist
wirklich noch mal eine nummer härter allerdings die neuesten captures sind ja
keine captures also die haben ja ihr was ist wie capture und so was das wird ja
alles jetzt angepasst dass die versuchen randomness aus dem browser zu sammeln
und zu gucken ob du ein mensch bist und so was also die da sie neuesten captures
brauchen keine captures mehr damit sie damit das captures sind so wisst ihr was
ich meine ich nicht also die haben das geupdatet dass man halt dass die die
versuchen anhand des browser verhaltens zu erkennen ob man ein mensch ist oder
nicht das scheint ganz gut zu klappen weil
immer mehr immer mehr seiten steigen darauf um so also was muss man jetzt machen
sudo bash kasm-release install also doch install install install.sh zack yes
einmal maus im kreis drehen lassen der bot wird nicht mehr erkannt
exzellent das wird so wie es gehen
Microsoft hat Bethesda gekauft echt und das war aber ganz schön teuer die
brauchen exklusivtitel oder war oder war fallout die sich so den reinfall
dass sie nichts mehr wert waren
ok das ist auch zeni max und das ganze kram geht fort
so wie viel ach ja ein schnapper 7,5 milliarden minecraft gab es noch für eine
milliarde
den kennt ihr alle den typ kennt ihr alle wenn er ihn
seht das ist der fallout 76 irgendwie 16 fach größere welt typ der nut ist das
den kennt mittlerweile jeder
ok ist ja gut was macht der install ach du scheiße was macht ein installer
dafür installer dinge der installer soll einfach ist ich lasse ihn einfach
installen und gut ist also 7,5 milliarden das ist tatsächlich doch schon mal
ordentlich dass das spiele gehören zukunft zum game pass das ist tatsächlich
ganz praktisch umso weniger fragmentierung in dem bereich umso
besser natürlich auch weniger konkurrenz mal gucken mal gucken was die games da
läuft dazu sagen kann ja nur besser werden
ehrlich gesagt ohne mist ich finde ich auch ja finde ich auch man kann von
microsoft ja letztendlich halten was man will aber die haben die letzten jahre
über doch ganz gute sachen teilweise gemacht die haben auch sachen komplett
verschissen und letztendlich darf man nicht vergessen
microsoft ist nach wie vor ein ladendienst hauptsächlich halt darum
geht kohle zu scheffeln wie allen anderen auch aber irgendwie ist mir
microsoft mittlerweile rups microsoft 2020 ist mir deutlich sympathischer als
das microsoft 2000 rum da lohnt sich der game pass immer da hat er recht
das das wohl war ja
microsoft ist das also bei microsoft kann man auch nicht mal sagen dass sie
nicht mal nicht mehr komplett anti open source sind die sind sogar mittlerweile
sehr viel pro open source moment hat hat das jetzt funktioniert oder es ist jetzt
einfach abgebrochen zwischendurch glaubt es ist einfach zwischendurch
abgebrochen das funk zählt ja schon mal gut
fürs einfach noch mal aus
what the fuck
ok ich ich mache ich mache ich mache ich mache
wow was macht das da der installer scheint mir noch ein bisschen noch ein
bisschen verbackt zu sein vor allem wenn dazwischen drin ab ist jetzt hat es jetzt
wieder abgebrochen
also ist er jetzt abgebrochen läuft jetzt
doch gar läuft gar nicht
laufen tut hier nix um an jetzt nicht installiert zack kann man kann immer nur
zwei stunden am tag benutzen weiß ich nicht wie kommst du da drauf steht das
irgendwo das wäre das wäre das wäre fail wenn das nur so ist so nö da läuft
nix hast du den gesucht ja ich würde den installen einfach so oft aus bis es
funktioniert ab gerade in stil nach und unter dem admin user steht das ok das
wäre fail wenn man das nur maximal zwei stunden am tag verwenden darf
ernsthaft das wäre natürlich aber sehen wir ja gleich falls es funktioniert
ok jetzt kann er anscheinend pullen der installer scheint mir noch ein wenig
verbesserungswürdig zu sein wenn er einfach so crash zwischendurch endlich
pullern jetzt geht's was hat er denn für schmerzen die docker die docker
registry aber ihr seht der installer macht jedes mal ein bisschen mehr wenn
ihr einen kleinen online shop erstellen würdet was würdet ihr da empfehlen ohne
viel eigenem auffang zu investieren shopify
warte mal nicht dass ich jetzt warte mal war shopify die sache wo man den shop
bauen konnte aber shopify die sache wo man abrechnen konnte oder beides ne das
war das ja shopify
ich muss dir aber sagen ich habe damit keine persönlichen erfahrungen ich habe
jetzt bloß von ein paar leuten gehört deswegen bin ich da jetzt auch so schnell
drauf gekommen dass das ganz ok ist
29 dollar im monat klingt doch klingt doch fair da gibt es bestimmt alternativen
die günstiger sind garantiert shopify alternativen
big e-commerce square space habe ich auch schon mal irgendwo gehört kann das
sein dass die youtube werbung machen
shopify mit job shipping reich in zwei tagen wenn der so einfach wäre
oh guck mal den installer ist durchgelaufen den installer ist durch easy einfach fünf
mal ausgeführt zack so muss den installer sein ok also dann probieren wir
mal aus was haben wir für eine ip 30 milliaren interfaces was haben wir für
eine ip so die und jetzt brauchen noch das password copy paste mir das mal das
ist ein password manager landet so und nun probieren wir das mal aus wir gehen
einfach mal hier rein in soll ich sag jetzt ok ich brauche jetzt ein neues ein
neuen anonymen browser oder was auch immer um mal irgendwas ausprobieren zu
können oder auf irgendeine seite zu gehen wo ich nicht mit windows hin will
gehen wir mal hin wahrscheinlich hatte tps jawoll ok das lässt sich einfach
fixen da sind wir log in so log in als admin und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob
man das wirklich nur zwei zwei stunden verwenden darf
ja jetzt haben wir eingeloggt ok das war ziemlich einfach zu installieren
moin kenny das war easy so und was gibt es jetzt hier zur auswahl standardmäßig
chrome desktop firefox desktop deluxe und einen tor browser
jetzt probieren wir mal der reihe nach aus was ist einfach nur chrome
keine keine keine tips gehste weg und zack haben wir einen chrome wir haben
ein chrome im chrome excellent chromeception wir haben ein chrome im
chrome das war jetzt das war jetzt wirklich ziemlich einfach ne
hast du was gehört ob es ein termin für edge und linux gibt nee aber wozu
macht der ein x-server und überträgt das per websocket ich vermute mal dass der
kein dass der kein dass er das nicht per websocket macht sondern dass der
einfach bilder ab ruft oder so was kann man hier alles auswählen clipboard gut
zum scheren was steht natürlich drinnen das muss sein 1 ach hier kann man sagen
lockout oder destroy das heißt wenn ich hier fertig bin ausblühen kann ich die
kann ich die session quasi gleich schon wieder wegschmeißen ich kann sachen
downloaden von der vm sachen abladen audio an die auswahl mikrofon auswahl
video ok don't show tips jetzt sieht es ein bisschen besser aus also
wahrscheinlich überträgt der einzelne bilder denke ich mal irgendwelche bilder
diffs oder so ich glaube nicht dass es großartig optimiert ist sharing was ist
view only access das müssten ja klappt mal in der cloud installieren und gucken
ob das ob der twitch chat read only drauf zugreifen kann und wie sicher das
ist
das mache ich nicht dann habe ich instant irgendwelche leute die dort
china illegalen china kram drauf machen
soll ich das mal auf manien ist nicht baro bloß nicht bloß nicht installieren
und scheren hier dann hast du inziden auf deiner kiste
irgendwelche china kram drauf den ich drauf haben ist also falls es nur mir
scheren willst ich probiere es nachher mal selbst auf eine cloud kiste aus musste
nicht wozu ist so was gut du kriegst auf einen klick einen frischen frischen
browser auf linux basis also sprich du bist schon mal nicht anfällig für die
ganzen linux kisten für die ganzen winnows sicherheitslücken und sachen und
du kannst danach wieder wegschmeißen was ist nächstes mal eine klinik session
das erscheint mir relativ praktisch so als haben wir quasi einfach nur ein
chrome im chrome mal guckt mal gucken wie gut youtube läuft wahrscheinlich gar
nicht
zeig mal den desktop na gut ich habe gerade die chrome session gestartet da
gibt es kein desktop youtube nervt mich so chicken hacks boy
after ok das müssen wir uns jetzt unbedingt angucken
ok die der sound geht schon mal
alles klar 720p ist ein bisschen pixellig aber das ist ok damit kann ich leben
o
wenn der wüsste was die an weihnachten mit dem hunn machen
aber vielleicht sind sie einfach nur einfach nur lege henne und mit dem
hunn passiert nix so es läuft aber nur eigentlich ganz gut oder
also es ist nicht wirklich lokal mäßig schnell aber es funktioniert zumal youtube
ja nicht wirklich der scope von sowas ist was passiert wenn ich chrome zumache
dann starte das wieder ok ist das nicht einfach nur vnc über browser
wahrscheinlich schon ja wahrscheinlich schon aber das setup ist easy so und
jetzt kann man sagen destroy und danach ist die session weg man kann sie neu
starten mit komplett komplett fresh usage moment
ob das bedeute dass man es wirklich nur zwei stunden benutzen kann das glaube
ich nicht
das wäre total bescheuert
das ist ein limit für den user vielleicht
das ist wahrscheinlich limit für den user oder so ich glaube nicht dass das
wirklich das wert das wäre total hängen geblieben also zum beispiel wofür das
ganz nützlich ist was das ist das erste was mir jetzt einfällt ist man hat ein
server im internet man macht weil ich meine man muss natürlich hier vor
irgendwie autodiffizierung zeug man also musste in reverse proxy mit mit
passwort autodiffizierung machen schon mal in die settings ganz unten
genau also sprich man machte einen proxy davor mit autodiffizierung und dann kann
man von unterwegs von der arbeit oder von sonst wo hat man eine sichere browser
umgebung ja also es gibt ja es gibt ja genug genug firmen da ist es
beispielsweise nicht erlaubt dass man mal irgendwie was privat nachguckt und man
muss wenn man doch mal ganz wichtig was privat nachgucken muss dann lieber über
sowas komplett verschlüsselt oder aber es gibt auch firmen dies erlauben aber
man möchte vielleicht nicht von der arbeitswindows kiste sich bei boomer book
oder so einlocken dann macht man so was mit einer wegwerf session das ist gar
nicht gar nicht verkehrt ja
als ich bin ab und ich darf das eh neu benutzt ok wir gucken uns jetzt mal den
desktop an wir gucken wir gucken uns aber gleich den desktop deluxe an wenn schon
wenn schon dann gleich danach gucken wir uns noch mal den top browser an ob das
auch gut funktioniert also eins muss man ihn lassen die
integration ist wirklich ist wirklich gut da das geht das geht echt zackig und
kann sich kann sich nicht beschweren das läuft das läuft gut
was spricht gegen den cognitive modus von irgendeinem browser ist es immer noch
ein browser unter windows das heißt wenn du wirklich mal auf eine
seite gehen willst der du ganz und gar nicht traust dann würde ich das auf keinen
fall von dem browser machen unter windows aus und wenn du willst dass
danach auch rückstandslos alles weg ist dann ist sowas hier gar nicht praktisch
klar ich meine wenn du daheim bist kannst du auch eine vm starten und dort
mit dem browser drauf gehen das ist das juckt da nicht
ja du kannst genau du kannst zum beispiel auf viermund kannst du vm auf
usb stick mitnehmen aber hierfür brauchst du ja eigentlich nur einen
rechner mit interner zugang und am besten ist man nimmt man macht sich noch
eine domain und dann connect man sich ich finde die sache an sich echt nicht
verkehrt also gerade wenn man wenn man auf der arbeit ist und nicht die
windows kiste verwenden will um sag mal sich privat irgendwo einzuloggen auch
wenn man darf dann ist sowas praktisch das ist komplett verschlüsselt ssl
komplett verschlüsselt und wenn man da noch autentifizierungen als davor macht
ist das doch nicht nicht verkehrt übrigens max elektronik vier monate
excellent huge sprain subscription so was ist was ist auf dem desktop
folgendes ist ein ganz normales xf ce wie es aussieht mehrere des top so wie
sich das gehört
kann denn eine website inzwischen so viel schaden anrichten wenn man dort nicht
irgendwas runter geht klar das geht aber nicht mittlerweile es geht schon immer
das ist das nennt sich an drive bei also wenn der browser sicherheitslücken hat
den die webseite ausnutzt dann kannst du dir relativ einfach was einfangen wenn
du dann noch auf windows unterwegs bist
und die irgendwas aktuelles für windows haben dann haben die auch relativ
schnell adminrechte natürlich ist das mittlerweile das ist sogar mittlerweile
schwieriger als früher das ist das ist nicht mittlerweile es ist mittlerweile
sogar schwieriger als früher weil mittlerweile security maßnahmen was
windows angeht was browser angeht deutlich höheren standard haben oder
deutlich schwieriger ist als als früher aber es gibt ja trotzdem täglich was
also was haben wir hier schönes vor installiert
es fühlt sich also für das dass das irgendwie vnc über browser ist fühlt
sich das verhältnismäßig flüssig an das ist jetzt keine kein vergleich mit
einer lokalen vm oder so aber aber es geht es geht
es geht
so was haben an freunds entwirkt studio code von
das geht es ist sogar halbwegs aktuell ich glaube das ist sogar aktuell oder 1473
man kann lizenzen kaufen oder hat das nur ein ja das wäre natürlich beknackt vor
allem ich installe es ja selbst hier leisen singen
soll ich da fack der unlicensed version offen mit fünf konkurrent users ich bin
ja geneigt das mal zwei stunden offen zu lassen und zu gucken was passiert weil
weil sollte das wirklich nur zwei stunden gehen dann wäre das wäre das
schon ziemlich fehl
limit time
das time limit einfach zwei stunden time specified in minutes ok
time an die eidl connection kann ich kann ich kann mir das irgendwie dann
vorstellen aber wir gucken jetzt erst mal was alles drauf ist bevor wir uns hier
die settings nochmal näher angucken also man hat nur studio code drauf das ist
ganz praktisch also ich stelle mir vor dass man hier auch mal ganz gut ein paar
sachen ausprobieren kann über halt einen halbwegs sicheren remote desktop
manchmal können natürlich auch das ganze über vpn von daheim aus verwenden
auch eine möglichkeit weil so braucht man ja nix man braucht einfach nur den
browser wir müssen jetzt mal ausprobieren wie
gut das über touch funktioniert aber wahrscheinlich nicht nicht so gut
hat man hier nicht irgendwo moment wir sind auch hier in chrome man konnte auch
hier irgendwas was ff 11 developer tools f 12 console ja ok wir simulieren mal
touch naja es ist halt ein desktop
in chrome nicht wirklich gut gut funktioniert mit touch na also für also
für touch für touch ist es nicht für touch ist es nicht ausgelegt
wie sieht das auf einem tablet aus gucken wir mal und wenn ich macht es mal
zu naja es ist halt es ist halt absolut nicht für touch gedacht man merkt auch
hier kann es hier mit touch nix gescheit bedienen also eher nix eher nix also nur
sehr behelfsmäßig wenn man das mobile verwenden muss
aber von der idee her finde ich das wirklich cool was sagt denn wie viel zeit
ich jetzt schon verwendet habe moment also mal erst mal auf die
richtige seite 0,2 also wenn der mich wirklich nach zwei stunden
rausschmeißt wäre das hardcore fail was ist die meinung zu geforce now ich
finde das eigentlich ganz gut leider machen immer wenige hersteller mit und
es wird deswegen uninteressanter
die haben ja am anfang gesagt man kann steam bibliothek sinken und das hat auch
gut funktioniert und dann haben die nach und nach ihre spiele rausgenommen aus
geforce now aber ansonsten muss ich ehrlich sagen finde ich ist die force
now der beste streaming service da können die da kann google mit stadia mal ganz schnell aber gut
stadia ist halt schon seit jeher stadia oder eigentlich ist stadia eher
der desktop ist an einer stunde weg hallo sound
es ist einfach jetzt mittendrin hat es einfach mittendrin angehalten oder wie
ich glaube das ist ein timeout nach einer stunde wenn ich jetzt hier rum klicke geht
es nicht zu oder
geht das wirklich nach einer stunde expires on 21 uhr ja tatsächlich geht es
dann einfach aus
ja das ist aber doof
leisens limit 5 leisenden
warum ist es jetzt so laut auf einmal die musik ist ja
selbstverstörungen wird eingeleitet
sehr merkwürdig
settings machst du hier session lifetime kann man hier einfach
easy
ich mache es mal weg und neu auf und dann gucken wir mal ob die session wir gucken
mal wie die torte nehmen wir machen noch mal den desktop deluxe auf
aber das geht schön schnell also das gefällt mir dass das hat was an sich finde ich ist eine
gute idee ne ne ne ne ne das expired das finde ich das finde ich doof dass das
einfach so dass es sagt hier kann man auch nichts einstellen
woops was auch immer immer dass alles sein soll
jeder müssen wir das noch mal einfach laufen lassen im hintergrund und gucken
was passiert aber was kann man sonst noch machen
lounge now ach das ist wenn ich hier nicht was auswählen will ja ok ok kann
man kann man machen kann ich war kann ich mehrere sachen gleichzeitig also
desktop desktop starten war ein chrome starten war und ja das läuft alles
gleichzeitig und den tor browser starten wir limit exceeded for user man darf
maximal zwei stück haben limit limit wo setzt man die limits
casums wo setzt man die limits ich würde ja eigentlich sagen in den group settings
oder in den user settings aber
das geht anscheinend netz
laudoku kann man in den group settings ok guck mal group settings
die limits sind abhängig vom licensing ja glaube ich auch glaube ich auch die
wollen halt auch kohle verdienen aber zwei stunden ist schon ist schon doof
create new image
ach guck mal da kann man direkt einen docker file angeben und sich eine
eigenen desktop bauen desktop bauen ist eigentlich ganz nett aber zwei stunden
ist doch schon ein bisschen wenig hier session lifetime habe ich ja schon
hochgestellt das bringt schon mal nix
ja das problem ist dass das alles weg ist 95
ach guck mal die haben so hilfetexte dabei
nee das ist das ist wahrscheinlich mit das ist wahrscheinlich nicht drinne mit
dem standard lizenz das ist aber doof dann kann man es gar nicht richtig
verwenden da so cool ich so cool ich das jetzt fand aber gut ich meine die
müssen ja auch ich ich meine ich kann auf der einen seite verstehen dass die
kohle verdienen müssen aber zwei stunden das macht ja schon fast an
usable ok machen wir jetzt noch mal chrome zu
und machen wir noch mal ein tor browser auf und gucken ob das gut funktioniert
tor broser update na dann machen update
ja tor downloads sind ja bekannt für absolut huge geschwindigkeit ja zwei
stunden pro pro vm zum weg wäre oder pro pro container zum wegwerfen aber zwei
stunden am tag ist schon ganz schön wenig wenn ich kann mir mehrere user
anlegen und das dann switchen oder so aber es irgendwie doof
was kosten denn so lizenzen zeig mal ja
seit man ja licensing hallo wo steht denn was es kostet products pricing hier
free fünf simultaneous session limits das wäre ja ok
das steht nix von time limits das steht nix von time limits ich meine dass es
fünf fünf simultaneous session limits hat das ist ok
das steht nix von time limit also ich bin ja wirklich gespannt session lifetime
group was allow
nee das ist was anderes usage limit hier ok das geht angeblich angeblich geht das
in group settings so das ok das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren wenn ist die ist
die ist es ziemlich bescheuert platziert so erst mal gucken tor browser
funktionierter kram
tor browser keine ahnung heise die muss man unbedingt anonym aufmachen
ja funst
so jetzt haben wir einmal anonym heise abgerufen excellent destroy bäm session
weg also ich finde ich die idee dahinter echt cool so also group settings group
group settings wie komme ich überhaupt auf group settings wie komme ich auf
group settings groups group properties das sind aber nicht die settings die ich
habe das sind andere settings die man hier sieht leg mal eine neue gruppe an
exakt prudermus los bester krumm da war ja keine ahnung zählen
wieso hast du das in deinem auto so gute frage was habe ich noch in mein auto
prudermus los pock like this wein monka db keck weg kein komodate
ich habe keine ahnung warum ich das auto weil kraut meint das hier ist
kontextmäßig das wo ich prudermus los reinschreiben will
group settings wie komm ich in group gibt es das bei mir net
das sieht bei mir aber anders aus das gibt es bei mir nicht was oben steht wo
wo steht create setting create group steht hier oben das
select group tab from navigation habe ich doch
jesus ich bin hier glaub schon richtig aber die settings sehen bei mir anders
aus ok das verwirrt mich jetzt echt
ok kein schimmer also vielleicht geht das in der community
community version nicht vielleicht ist das premium feature ja
ach du scheiße ist das versteckt meine güte da kommt auch nicht da kommt
an da kommt auch keiner drauf ok et setting also ok wie ist das ich hab
es noch copy past usage limit usage usage limit per user interval daily
hours 24 es reicht am tag würde ich sagen
add oder auch nicht moment welche welche gruppe habe ich
überhaupt angepasst jetzt ich habe prudermus los angepasst oder
all users all users ich pass mal admin an wobei ich bin da drinne users in
group admin vielleicht muss ich mich neu einloggen usage limit per user per
group per user daily ok wir machen jetzt einfach vielleicht vielleicht check da
24 mal 12 und gucken ob sich das dann irgendwie ändert ok jetzt über das
ausloggen logout jawoll log in was weiß ich wie das password war über das
password so hier exzellent zwei stunden ja da sind wir gerade
usage limit haben wir noch festgelegt
spawn mal eine neue vor mir aber das hier oben ist ja vor allem
unabhängig das hier dürfte erst mal egal sein
ich gebe dem admin user auch noch mal unlimited
ah guck mal es gilt es gilt dass es gilt das kleinere von bein guck mal da per
user limit 2 so da mal mit 12 rein update zack 12 hat doch nichts mit
lizenzen zu tun aber es ist es ist versteckt es fuck oder also mehr
verstecken hätten sie das echt nicht können easy easy ist settings auf mal
live ja kippe live ist es ist 3000 ist 3600 ist das eine stunde
ne 3600 sekunden ist das eine stunde wir machen jetzt einfach mal 7200 hin ok
usage limit also 24 total 24 stunden pro tag exzellent es ist sehr sinnvoll für
den admin zwei stunden anzunehmen so 24 alles klar desktop deluxe easy
das ist der desktop home und jetzt geht es auch zwei stunden also leute hat
nichts mit lizenzen zu tun man kann alles einstellen die settings sind nur
sehr gut versteckt
also jetzt kann ich mir den desktop noch mal weiter angucken also was haben wir
hier drauf slack
remote desktop gedöns oh das ist ja big brain jetzt kann man es mir vollkommen
egal jetzt das heißt ich könnte remote desktop im remote desktop im im im
browser remote machen oder was das ist dann aber schon abgedreht also ist das
quasi eine vm im browser so ungefähr es ist recht abgespecktes recht
abgespeckter linux container also sprich du brauchst da nicht viel ram für also
nicht viel extra ram was haben wir sonst noch hier drauf und es lässt sich halt
total schnell was ist das für ein button da oben internet connection total schnell
erzeugen und zerstören und das praktische ist dass du halt jedes mal
eine neue session haben kannst wenn du willst
ach guck mal doch hier kann man kann man resizen ohne anzuklicken ja genau neues
testament genau für sowas stelle ich mir vor dass es gut ist
er schreibt hier nämlich grad also könnte man ein internet kaffee gehen dann
über diesen dienst sein deshalb ja genau dafür stelle ich mir nämlich auch vor
dass es gut ist wenn man unterwegs ist wenn man auf der arbeit ist und mal was
privates nachgucken will wenn man denn darf aber es halt nicht über den
windows rechner von der arbeit machen will ist das eigentlich ziemlich
ziemlich praktisch ja sehe ich auch so vielleicht installiere ich mir das doch
mal auf irgendeiner keine ahnung hetzener cloud oder so mit einem reverse
proxy davor dass man password identifizierung hat weil weil direkt ins
internet stellen will ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht oder noch besser per vpn
allerdings was richtig wisst ihr was richtig cool wäre wenn das auf dem
raspberry pi laufen würde weil dann könnte man es direkt hinter
seine fritzbox stellen dann wird meine raspberry pi einfach direkt hinter die
fritzbox an direkt an die fritzbox anstöpseln und einfach eine port weiter
leitung auf die raspberry pi machen und dann hätte man keinen zugriff ins
interne netz nur auf das netz zwischen meine zwischen der fritzbox und dem
guter leider läuft das auf einem ja oder
x68 sport kaufen genau oder genug oder irgendwas leider läuft das halt nicht
auf dem raspberry pi genug power für so ein bisschen das hier hätte der mit
sicherheit gerade für ein user die sind da richtig old school mit
supplying text kann mich noch dran erinnern als so plein text hier der
neueste revolutionärer shit war
ok also muss man muss ja man muss ja sagen so bleibt text versus studio also
es ist immer noch rein von der performance her not even close so was
haben wir sonst noch drauf slack warum starte ich das geht's mal fort kann man
das auch als docker container stand den server selbst glaube ich nicht weil die
benutzen ja selbst docker zu managen
allerdings geht das ja auch also man kann ja auch aus docker docker managen
man muss einfach nur den docker socket durchreichen
ich glaube das hat einfach nur noch keiner hat einfach nur noch keiner
verpackt als docker image oh ich glaube ich habe die netzwerkonfig gerade
gequittet so eine gute idee war warum kann man einfach die netzwerkonfig
quitten
okay ne geht noch was haben wir sonst noch ohne die office das
irgend so dem microsoft office 360 verschnitt ja sieht so sieht sogar schon
ein bisschen so aus
die get textverarbeitung
schlimmste kategorie software die es überhaupt gibt warum sollte das nicht
aber das bei laufen weil die offiziell keinerlei armen support haben so was
aber noch teams haben noch drauf aber nur alle neue version ja das kenne ich
seito tv aber da muss man sich um die kisten auf die man sich connected dahinter
selbst kümmern und das hier macht halt alles für dich ich
finde echt dass das seinen scham hat so jetzt probieren wir mal wie das mit
upload und download aussieht also mal hier zu mal angenommen ich möchte jetzt
dateien hochladen mal angenommen ich bin auf der arbeit und keine ahnung mit
irgendwas runterladen hochladen was auch immer so mal ausprobieren wie das
funktioniert zack
keine ahnung dass ich mal beispielsweise mal ein key pass runter lade dass ich mich
irgendwo einloggen kann upload ok das heißt was ich hier
reinschiebe kann ich downloaden put studio verknüpfung schieben wir da mal
ein
download
aber guck mal jetzt habe ich die studio verknüpfung runtergeladen
exzellent die die habe ich schon immer mal gebraucht so und jetzt uploaden wir
mal was das geht doch verhältnismäßig einfach also da haben sie sich haben sie
wirklich gut gedanken gemacht upload hier pippo pett
da ist er
nice
so multiple desktops funktionieren auch wenn ich das hier richtig sehe also man
kann sogar ganz abgedrehte sachen machen also irgendwie teams hier aufmachen
kann man nicht kann ich nicht einloggen aber auch multiple desktops funktionieren
auch also damit kann man sogar halbwegs remote was machen
das ist eine coole idee mir gefällt das also ich das hat was ich finde das
wirklich nice wenn man das jetzt noch kup wenn man das jetzt noch kombiniert
mit sagen wir mal im reverse proxy für authentifizierung und letzten krippter
vor dann ist das wirklich praktisch
die andere sache ist nur die aber bei nie das mit dem mit dem mit dem limit
haben wir jetzt ja das limit gibt es ja nicht das das war das war nur ein
bisschen unglücklich voreingestellt so und wenn ich einfach nur logout mache
das probieren wir jetzt mal wenn ich einfach logout mache dann sollte er die
sachen bei behalten probieren wir mal aus bla bla bla safe
auf dem desktop so und jetzt sagen wir logout
logout achso moment war das password nee da da ist das password
so login und jetzt kann man es weitermachen
es ist das ist echt praktisch läuft das team auch drauf ich glaube
nachinstallieren kann man nix würde mich jetzt wundern wenn man da was
nachinstallieren könnte großartig aber in abt abt search in die team gibt es ja
gar nicht was die haben mittlerweile unter buddho den steaming stoller dabei
excellent also ok
oh ich darf kein user switchen
ja gut wenn ich kein user switchen darf dann kann ich auch nicht nix nix
nachinstallieren
brauche man für steam admin rechte moment wo ist da chrome nee nee sudo
minus i kann ich nicht machen sudo ist nicht drauf sudo ist nicht
drauf und so geht auch nicht steam install brauche man für steam admin
rechte kann man es nicht so installieren
jetzt sich einfach mal den download link steam install steam achso nee dafür
brauche ich admin rechte als debian package
ja gut also wie man das tut wie man da root rechte kriegt wäre halt die frage
drauf
ich vermute mal dass es absichtlich so gemacht dass man kein user wechseln
kann geben ich gebe davon also ich fühle das
wurde ausgehend dass es absichtlich so gemacht
es sagt doch ihr könnt also so ist ja drauf also man kann einfach den user
nicht wechseln ich könnte mir den image bauen aber da habe ich jetzt keinen bock
drauf ihr müsst ihr wahrscheinlich ein eigenes docker fall zusammenwursten für
weil können wir schnell gucken wie einfach das einfach ist
schauen wir mal destroy machen wir weg bäm
rip vm jetzt wie geht das images create new image die kann ich nicht einfach
darauf aufbauen auf so einem image haben wir mal hier das desktop desktop deluxe
image
docker extra konfig kann man da irgendwelche custom script commands
reinschreiben für was verwendet man die rechte wenn man da keine software
seleniar in prosen zum beispiel
docker extra konfig kann man da irgendwie reinschreiben run ab install
oder so
ok was kann man da reinschreiben
go
first launch
kann man da ab installen oder so
ach nee im moment ist was anderes
das team kann sie voll knicken aber es geht ja generell um packages wie man
das nach installieren kann ok das bringt mir wahrscheinlich nicht
allzu viel
ok ich probiere das trotzdem aus was man dann ab ab ab install
klar irgendwas was nicht drauf ist machen ja was blabla blabla blabla blabla
ok
ok erkennst ja kaum was drin ab install steam installer ist das na ab install
minus y submit oh invalid jason warum ist das jason invalid geht das
environment brauchen wir nicht wegen dem comma so was war das was habe ich jetzt
endlich in den deluxe deluxe desktops ob der sind ob der sind steam installer
rund die nähe
nähe anscheinend gut dass da muss man sich jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer mit
mit beschäftigen ob ganz glaube ganz so einfach ist es dann doch nicht
es wäre halt gut wenn man auf dem image aus auf bau nein nein ich will mich
auch so auf dem image aufbauen könnte
dem installer aber mein befehl ist ja schon richtig
ne alle ich will copy pasten copy paste geht nicht warum doch copy paste geht
exzellent
ok das würde richtig heißen genau stimmt stimmt der führt das der führt
das mit meinem user wahrscheinlich aus und deswegen geht das gar nicht
ne das das muss das muss irgendwie anders gehen nicht hier drüber das muss
man sich mal genauer angucken aber ich glaube das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen
langwierig
aber auf jeden fall eine coole sache das gefällt mir also das ist eine gut das
ist das ist auch wirklich easy zu installieren damit da kann man da kann
man gar nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen
docker rand konfig da kann man mit sicherheit irgendwas irgendwas übergeben
ich habe eine idee dass wir machen was wir machen können wir starten das jetzt
noch mal ich gehe jetzt ok das funktioniert aber ich glaube das ist
nicht in uns weg der sache ich mache jetzt einfach docker ps oder sudo ja
mein wegen docker ps und dann gucke ich welche vm da gerade welcher container da
gerade läuft der da
vermute ich mal laughing keller alles klar
ja so jetzt einmal das docker enter ne exac was na haha hat es jetzt
funktioniert mit attach
ab install steam installer moment minus seh fack der macht das als der macht das
als die sind diese dings dieser komische user da ok da fällt mir jetzt nichts ein
dazu ne minus it ist doch nur dass es danach wieder löscht malerweise müsste es
doch so gehen docker exac basch
ne das funkt doch
was oder muss man minus it wirklich
tatsächlich aber das geht nicht jetzt bin ich mit dieser komischen user ne ok
das ist so gemacht dass es nicht funktioniert das näher ist das ist eine
zusatzsoftware die man auf dem ubuntu debian oder sonst was installieren kann
unter der haube wird garantiert in den vnc sein aber die integration finde ich
gut dass du einfach auf knopfdruck im browser
dir den desktop erzeugen kannst du danach wieder wegwerfen stimmt das
könnte man auch probieren ob man an den user angeben kann aha ah ne keck weit fast
ok das ist ok es ist einfach nicht dafür gemacht ja es ist einfach nicht
dafür gemacht
zumal wenn ich da jetzt über die die admin konsole darum sauer hat es ja
keinen sinn das ist ja beim nächsten beim nächsten drauf und wieder weg
kann ich den gwim installieren wim btk das geht der war vorher nicht drauf und
jetzt ist er drauf
ja also man kann schon über fünf ecken die sachen nach installieren aber dann
ist es ja weg wenn ich es wieder lösche ne das geht das muss das muss bestimmt
irgendwie anders funktionieren ich leute ich will da kein steam ich will
er gar kein steam drauf installieren das ist ja komplett komplett sinnlos ich
wollte das gucken wie man allgemein sachen nach installieren kann so nice
also das das gefällt mir echt ganz gut nachdem wir jetzt auch das time limit
weg haben kann man das wirklich gut verwenden ich bin gerade am überlegen ob
ich mir nicht echt so ein ding auf auf in einem digital außen oder so was
aufsetzen soll dass man das remote verwenden kann ich
meine ich würde es ja lieber daheim über über port fighter leiter oder vpn
oder sonst wie verwenden
warte sie warum macht es gerade schon exzellent
was hey max fällt dir auf auf die schnelle ein buch ein mit dem man
spielerisch programmieren im besten falls die scharpe lernen kann spielerisch
ja nee nicht wirklich
nee
was ist eigentlich auf dieser seite hat damit jetzt nichts zu tun aber irgendwie
fällt mir das kann ein was ist eigentlich aus dieser seite geworden
wo man ich habe vergessen wie heißt coding girls oder so wo man die den ihr
konzept war dass sie den leuten quasi programmieren beibringen und für jeden
abgeschlossenen kurs haben sie sich einen kleinungsstück ausgezogen wie
hießen diese seite noch mal das war so ein total bescheuertes konzept wo ich
mir damals schon gedacht haben das wird im leben nicht klappen du kannst
nicht halbnackte mädels angucken dabei etwas lernen wollen das ist in
kombination vollkommen unrealistisch coding war das coding babes
ja genau
oh da was mache ich nicht auf das mache ich nicht auf auch wenn die seite auch
wenn die seite eigentlich save for work war
ich muss gerade mal in der browser vorschau gucken
ja doch genau die seite meine ich genau die seite meine ich die ist die ist die
ist komplett safe safe vor markt aber die idee war damals so so bescheuert ja
das hat mit also das hätte mich wirklich ganz stark gewundert wenn das
funktioniert hätte hier konnte man quasi html und so lernen und was ein
schwachsinn ja wundert mich nicht dass also das
wundert mich dass daraus nix geworden ist
naja da hat max 10 plus plus gelernt ja so gut wie ich 10 plus plus kann wäre
das möglich also ich kann es ja gar nicht gescheit
der rüppel elf monate huge subscription nice ab dankeschön also ich bräuchte es
halt um einigen studenten sie schaft näher zu bringen haben teilweise leute
von mir die noch nie eine richtige tastatur oh nee oh nee keine ahnung
keine ahnung übrigens das wäre jetzt ein schönes
beispiel gewesen was ich hier drüber hätte aufmachen können
der hätte ich erstmal den tor browser aufgemacht
hätte ich erstmal eine neue neue vor allem mit tor browser gestartet und da
drin hätte ich die seite dann aufgemacht und jetzt na nur mal so das
wäre jetzt ein gutes beispiel wofür man sowas gebrauchen kann
so man geht jetzt hier einfach auf frag mich bing oder so oder dak dak go und dann
sucht man nach der seite wo man hin will
und dann übrigens noch mal so noch so noch so ein channel wo ich mir auch so
denke was ist mit denen los ich gucke relativ viele heimautomatisierungs videos
weil es mir interessiert was andere leute so machen und es gibt die es gibt
so ein heimautomatisierungs channel okay ich meine über tor browser youtube ist
halt massif lahm es gibt so einen es gibt so einen heimautomatisierungs channel
wo auch wo auch so zwei drei medels rum stehen und halt die übelste boob cam am
start haben und hier dann über automatische türschlösser und so was
was erzählen wollen automation wie hieß denn dieser channel noch
mal atmar nee nee nee nee nee nee nee hier die genau das ist auch so geil mit
mit f da kriegst du irgendwie mit einfach einfach mal hardcore der
ausschnitt gefilmt und du kriegst dann was über wireless home security erzählt
es gibt schon paar merkwürdige channels irgendwie ich bin da kann mir doch da
kann mir doch keiner erzählen dass dieses video nicht gefilmt wurde im
hinblick gewisse regionen in den mittelpunkt zu rücken oder ist das
fachlich korrekt was ich da bisher gesehen habe ist schon okay so und das
wäre jetzt nur ein beispiel dafür um angenommen angenommen ihr wollt jetzt
nicht dass irgendjemand sieht dass ihr auf der seite drauf gewesen wart und
rückstandslos das ganze zu entfernen dann sagt jetzt einfach torsession destroy
und alles wieder weg das ist doch richtig top
also mordet 490 habe echt keine ahnung wie man das ganze spielerisch machen
könnte ich für mich ist ja immer so die große
motivation wenn man irgendwie schon weiß was man machen will und halt also
wenn man weiß was man machen will was rauskommen soll am ende und man sich
dann was raussucht mit dem man das umsetzen kann
dann ist man motiviert das problem ist halt wenn das leute sind die quasi nicht
mehr eine tastatur in der hand hatten dann ist dann ist den programmieren
beibringen schon echte hardcore aufgabe was sind diese cousin images wo hier das
da ja das ist was du als desktop also was du als session starten kannst du kannst
strom starten desktop desktop mit mehr was das war kann im anderen tap offen
ich habe so viel auf ich weiß nicht wo das ist schon die generation smart fold
in dem alter ja gut aber die generation smartphone die kann wunderbar snapchat
instagram und sonst was bedienen aber ich habe das gefühl dass die generation
smartphone ja fast noch mehr aufgeschmissen ist wenn sie sich selbst
was aneignen müssen technisch als die die boomer uns und zwischen smart form
und unsere generation so also die leute sind teilweise echt planlos
und das sagt die generation smartphone tatsächlich sogar selbst
bei dir funktioniert das install script sebaro einfach zehn mal ausführen dann
ging es bei mir so also das gefällt mir ich überlege mir gerade wie man das
absichern könnte also am liebsten am liebsten ja über vpn daheim allerdings
ich will kann vpn und keine port weiter leitung in mein internes netz daheim
haben also ist die beste variante eigentlich sich irgendwo
sagen wir mal einen hetzner cloud rechner zu mieten dort
inne meine du musst ja noch nicht mal let's encrypt machen aber wird sich
anbieten wenn man eh schon ein domain hat mal let's encrypt zertifikat und dann
irgendwie den kati oder in den engine x oder in anderen reverse proxy davor mit
anonymisierung der zu hause eine dmz einrichten bringt ja nichts ich habe ja
theoretisch eine nämlich die zone zwischen fritz box und internem router
das ist ja quasi sowas wie eine dmz das problem ist nur dass ich kein rechner
habe um den also ich habe genug rechner aber keinen den der sich dafür eignen
würde den dort anzuschließen so raspberry pi 4 würde sich wunderbar eignen
aber leider und das ist auch zur größte größte knackpunkt an dieser an dieser
lösung das läuft nicht auf raspberry pi
nämlich dorf ist
aber guck mal das ist wirklich gut gemacht das ist zackig schnell
funktioniert da muss man was überlegen hast du nicht noch x86 spärrechner doch
doch jede menge aber nichts was ich 24 7 strom sparen laufen lassen kann ja also
wie könnte wie könnte man das jetzt gut gut machen also ich mein also was wird
sich anbieten der kram kostet viel ich zeige es euch mal
prising der kram ist wirklich ultra billig so was reicht ja schon
was hältst du von den neuen konsolen bisher eigentlich nix um ehrlich zu
sein also nein moment ich meine mit nix jetzt nicht schlecht ich habe dazu keine
meinung wirklich ich weiß nur dass ich mir die definitiv nicht so release
kaufen würde kaufen werde weil die xbox 1 so release oder generell die ganze
xbox 1 war komplett reinfall und die ps4 hat mich geärgert mit wir machen eine
pro nach drei jahren und scheißen drauf dass ihr geld ausgegeben habt
und deswegen kaufe ich mir weder eine ps5 noch eine xbox ich weiß ich weiß
auch nicht mal wie die heißt ehrlich gesagt ich bin im kopf immer noch bei
xbox gar nicht wie heißt die jetzt xbox series x oder so ne
total ja
das läuft mit docker auf dem pay nicht da hin das läuft leider nicht auf dem
pay weil die keine armen images haben also ich werde es so hand haben ich
werde mir die neue konsolen erst bestellen sobald es dort exklusive
spiele gibt die ich unbedingt spielen will und dann kaufe ich mir die genauso
wie bei der switch die switch habe ich mir gekauft ich habe genau aber wie
viele spiele habe ich für die switch mario galaxy mario odyssey links
awakening press of the wild mario kart
die mario kart habe ich auf der view gar nicht drei spiele exzellent drei spiele
habe ich auf der auf der switch hat sich auch voll gelohnt die switch zu
kaufen aber das war halt drei sachen nicht unbedingt spielen wollte dann passt
das
aber so eine hetzener kiste wird sich doch anbieten
dann macht man sich so eine hetzener kiste
ich habe mein hetzener login nicht sonst würde ich mich da jetzt einloggen und
es schnell erstellen hetzener login weiß ich nicht aus dem
kopf gar nicht
kein plus
hallo lasst mich zurück auf pricing the fuck zurück
weiß so also so eine kiste müsste eigentlich reichen der docker macht ja
an der performance nix großartig um nicht zu sagen eigentlich quasi quasi nix
error log schickter sebarro
wow aus sebarro was das für ein error log setting sieht feil ob was zum
machst du das als als normaler user in temp
das sieht irgendwie fehl aus macht es als machs machs als normaler user mit sudo
in temp die haben bestimmt hardcoded fahre irgendwo drin
also immer du musst halt sudo starten alles gut dann ich gucke mal gerade ob ich
irgendwo mein hetzener login habe key pass
key pass muss ich mal kurz auf dem zweiten rechner nebenbei gucken
hetzener nee leider nicht
da kann ich es jetzt nicht machen sonst hätte ich jetzt noch mir so eine
kiste hier mal installiert aber preislich ist ok ich meine da bezahlt
2 9 3 2 2 89 von der leistung her und vom traffic und vom dings und müsste das
reichen für ein für 1 2 desktops und dann ist gut
glaubt das probiere ich nachher mal aus exzellent
passwörter lieber im buch oder auf dem pc speichern
naja also entweder du schreibst den kram wirklich offline auf was viel besser ist
als der ruf ne also die meisten leute wenn die sagen ich schreibe mir die
passwörter auf dem zettel da sagen nein wie kannst du das normal ganz ehrlich
das passwort auf den zettel schreiben ist gar nicht schlecht weil wenn ihr euch
irgendwas auf dem rechner einfangt den zugriff auf den zettel der bei euch im
schrank liegt hat keiner wenn ihr eine text datei auf dem desktop liegen habt
dann ist die kacke am dampfen also auf dem zettel ist nicht schlecht was
natürlich meiner meinung nach auch nicht verkehrt ist ist du nimmst sowas wie
in den key pass so was hier in so ein passport save allerdings muss man da
aufpassen wenn jemand deinen rechner mit
irgendeinem keylogger oder in einem rootkit oder sonst was ausstattet dann
ist das auch nicht mehr wirklich sicher
dann kann er zumindest mal den passport abgreifen wahrscheinlich auch sich das
key pass kopieren und dann das passwort von ihr eingeben was er abgegriffen hat
oder direkt oder direkt aus dem ram den kram abgreifen also ja das aber gut wenn
du ein rootkit auf dem rechner ist es vorbei
wenn du ein rootkit auf dem rechner hast bringt ja nicht mal zu zwei faktor
authentifizierung was
da lockst du dich nämlich ein machst zwei faktor authentifizierung und da greift
ab nachdem du dich eingeloggt hast also
also dass du kannst du kannst davon ausgehen wenn du wenn dein rechner
kompromittiert ist dann ist vorbei
den tru kütze überhaupt noch in keine ahnung verschlüsselung skram ist
aktuell in habe ich aber auch schon lang nichts mehr von gehört ich habe nur
letztens gelesen dass in den krankenhaus wurde wieder verschlüsselt das macht
mir dann immer das macht mir dann immer ein bisschen sorgen wenn ich sehe dass
das krankenhaus irgendwie übers internet erreichbar ist also interne
krankenhausinfrastruktur übers internet erreichbar ist das macht mir dann immer
ein bisschen ein bisschen gedanken
ich meine ich bin ich meine eigentlich dürfte ich mir da keine gedanken machen
weil wie gesagt ich war mit meiner mutter im krankenhaus und das erste was
sie gemacht haben ist wenn aus xp gebootet
da ist sogar einer gestorben weiß ich nicht keine ahnung das habe ich nicht
nicht weiter verfolgt aber als ich gesehen habe dass die an
ingener an in einem gerät erst mal wenn aus xp gestartet haben als wir da
reingekommen sind da hat es schon gereicht
aber das wurde nur versehentlich verschlüsselt die wollten die uni von
der stadt erbitten echt ich wusste ich habe die news nicht
mehr
eckerangriff auf uni klinik dusseldorf starb eine patientin rtl online ok das
war das war uni klinik was dusseldorf
was und die wollten gar nicht das erwischen die haben das falsche
verschlüsseln oder was
ach die wollten die uni verschlüsseln und haben die uni klinik erwischt oder
was
du kannst dich noch nicht mal auf die hacker verlassen dass die das richtige
hacken mittlerweile adonix die chance ist verstrichen gerade vor zwei wochen da
waren zusammen sushi futtert aber dankeschön drei monate exzellent
na gut wahrscheinlich waren es irgendwelche indischen hacker oder so die
random geguckt haben wo ist was auf und die haben den unterschied zwischen uni
klinik und uni nicht kapiert ist auch klar wenn du kein deutsch kannst ist auch
schwierig und dann verschlüsselt auch mal das falsche
die haben die schlüssel rausgekriegt wie das hat man ihnen gesagt hier ist ein
krankenhaus und leute sterben wenn ihr das nicht macht das finde ich ja
tatsächlich bemerkenswert dass die auf so was eingehen
tja ups ne plus plus geben wir heute wirklich nicht heute nicht heute kein
plus plus ich überlege mir immer noch wie ich das am besten wie ich das am
besten von außen zugreifbar mache
irgendwie mit einem ja irgendwo in der cloud installieren ist eigentlich am
sinnvollsten dann alternatifizierung davor
dann alternatifizierung davor und gut ist
ja na gut ich würde sagen wir haben uns das jetzt ausführlich genug angeguckt
dieses teil ich finde es gut also es gibt ja wenig software wo ich hier im
stream ausprobieren wo ich dann wirklich sagt das ist nice aber das finde ich
gut gemacht das ist natürlich letztendlich unterm
strich altbekanntes das ist in den vnc und das ganze dann im browser das ist
jetzt nichts neues aber das ist schön integriert einfach gemacht geht zack ich
von der idee her finde ich gut
das gefällt mir c++ ransomware liveanalyse nähe da bin ich nicht gut
drinnen sowas
ich lerne keinen extra c++ bildsystem muss ich auch nicht weil mein c++
gedöns ist ja schon fix und fertig von esp 32 und vorkonfiguriert also ich kann
da gar nichts anderes machen
jo ich bin erst zwei stunden an leute mir kommt schon viel länger vor
sebaro ja im leben ich
es gibt sie unter webfilter
da kann man pornwebseiten blacklisten oder so dass das die leute nicht
verwenden ist schlecht
ich würde gerne auf sie meck wechseln die kompiliere ich c++ am besten auf
was weiß ich ich habe keine ahnung also ich meine das ernst ich habe echt wenig
plan von c++ die einzigen c++ sachen die ich mache sind sachen wo ich dazu
gezwungen werde c++ zu machen zum beispiel zum beispiel hier für diesen
esp 32 controller da muss ich das in c plus ich kann das nicht in einer
anderen sprache aus erzielt c++ machen und rast verwenden geht auch nicht weil
was ist in der preview version die kaum was kann auf dem esp 32
da kann ich dir echt nichts zu sagen
was wenn du mit einer rz ip servst wird dir klaut mit den captures ständig auf
den sack gehen
äh wo wo sollen wir klaut flair auch mit captures auf dem keks gehen
ich kann dir gerade nicht folgen
aber was hat klaut fler damit zu tun
ich miete mir bei hetzner klaut eine kiste mit public ip die haben doch
dann nicht automatisch klaut flair davor oder meinst du oder meinst du ich habe
bei mir webseiten die auf klaut flair laufen
ach so du meinst wenn ich aus der vm im browser auf webseiten gehe das hält
sich in grenzen ja du hast es stimmt hast recht ich
fand es aber bisher nicht so schlimm ich habe ja bisher wenn ich auf der
arbeit war habe ich ja auch per x-forwarding von der kiste gesurft
das ist auch statische ip das ging das ging
ja aber du hast du hast recht das kann durchaus passieren ja ja leute ich dann
bin ich eigentlich durch für heute mir fällt jetzt noch nichts nix nix
anderes mehr ein also das funktioniert gut ich finde es echt nicht schlecht ich
werde mal wenn mal die kiste ausschalten
könnte es das hart rauf gehen und sie runterfahren
sollte sie sich eigentlich ausschalten
drei stunden später
ja dann gehe ich jetzt was abend essen hat gut funktioniert
poggers vm ist kaputt vielleicht vielleicht fängt sich vmw jetzt ok 8
gigabyte ram sind für vmw einfach zu viel da kommen die nicht mit müssen sie
erst mal freeen hast du schon von microsoft und potesta gesagt ja habe ich
mir vorhin angeguckt 7,5 billion klingt erst mal ordentlich ansonsten ja mir ist
es tatsächlich auch lieber als andere microsoft ist ja in letzter zeit gar
nicht so übel man darf aber unterm strich halt nicht vergessen dass die
auch kohle verdienen wollen also dass die hauptsächlich kohle verdienen
wollen gibt es so für aktuelle github trends zeigt
man ja trending einmal am tag kann man da gucken stimmt was hat es damit eigentlich
auf sich githubs official command line tool das das ist jetzt voll im trend und
ich frage mich wozu was wofür ist das gut
es wird ja kein github ersatz sein
ach so das ist quasi in den command line github api rapper so was in der
reine das gibt es doch das gab es doch schon inoffiziell 1000 fach man
wahrscheinlich ist es von github schlicht und ergreifend besser integriert
ja gut ob das jetzt so geil ist ja das ist quasi in den command line github
api rapper wrapper ein wrapper ist das wenigstens unterstützen sie windows
package management wenn es microsoft schon hat macht
ist das was zusätzliches oder kannst du da normale github befehle auch drüber
ausführen also kann ich da drin auch normale normale github befehle ausführen
also geharr keine ahnung geharr status oder sowas oder ist das zusätzlich also
sprich das ist zusätzlich ok
ich muss euch ehrlich sagen also ich meine ich mache zwar ab und zu mal was
auf github aber es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich drei stunden am tag nur github
arbeit da irgendwie erledigen muss also für mich lohnt sich das tool jetzt
erst mal weniger würde ich sagen so was haben wir sonst noch kb knowledge base
manager der muss sein knowledge base schon managen einfach alles im kopf haben
ok so was ist mir zu umständlich das mache ich mit der steht in meinem
notizprogramm drin oder im zweifelsfall in dem doku wiki easily and secure send
things from one computer tun also aha
so quinn ok ach doch das kenne ich das ist auch schon alt
warum trendet das das ist uralt
obi zwar da war mobi nicht in audio player alter 58 was ist das denn 58.000
stimmt ja das recht mobi t oder so meine ich ja das ist ist original docker wie
und was ist docker dann wenn das original docker ist ok was auch immer
exzellent sebaro das ich schreibe dich gleich nach dem stream und ich probiere
es gleich nach dem stream aus ein c++ testing framework hier plus plus muss
man nicht testen das ist instant perfekt
freekat da gibt es kostenlose sachen ok da bin ich ja mal gespannt wann die
endlich raus wann man es endlich an die endlich viel drei releasing und ich bin
gespannt wann dort net core fünf als heißt ja nicht bei dort net core fünf
heißt ja nur noch dort net fünf microsoft verwirrt ja wieder leute das die
also ohne scheiß also die benahmung bei microsoft ist ja wieder absolut on point
was dort net fünf angeht es gibt das dort net framework für windows only mit
der version 4.8 es gibt dort net core bis version 3.1 so und die nächste version
heißt jetzt dort net fünf also ist jetzt kein framework drin und auch kein core
mehr drin allerdings ist dort net fünf kein nachfolger des dort net frameworks
4.8 was man denken würde sonder nachfolger von dort net core 3.1
alles klar
dazu kommt noch dass die produkte die sie damit ausliefern teilweise noch core im
namen haben nämlich dass bei asp dort net weiß ich es nicht allerdings asp dort
net wird wahrscheinlich weiterhin asp dort net core heißt genauso wie das
entity framework und da wird es ganz wir weil das entity framework also das ist
der das ist der datenbank mapper von von von asp dort net core der wird dann ja
wahrscheinlich entity framework core 5 heißen was dann weiterhin core heißt
was die leute aber extrem verwähren wird weil es gibt normales entity framework
west version 6 also wie gesagt die microsoft benahmung ist extrem und
point wieder auf der anderen seite mir fällt mir fällt auch nichts besseres
ein sebaro schallt lieber aus genau und dass das also was da dran wirklich
ziemlich gut ist dass in dort net fünf ist dort net core dort net framework und
mono alles in einem danach gibt es das andere zeugs nicht mehr
microsoft was view 3 ist released anstatt wandern wirklich
ach kommanda
ach guck mal das ist vor drei tagen rausgekommen ja das ist ja nice
oh das müssen wir uns im nächsten stream angucken das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt ich
habe nur mitbekommen dass halt dass sie sich seit jahren schon tutorials machen
über dinge die eingebaut wurden da wieder ausgebaut wurden und sonst was ja
nice das ist ja das ist cool das muss man in einem der nächsten da
müssen wir wieder mal zur abwechslung ein bisschen javascript machen weil ich
habe ein paar sachen gesehen die haben sich wirklich sehr nice angehört also
erstens mal dass es kleiner ist als view 2 dass man viele sachen einfach quasi
die man wenn man sie nicht verwendet brauchen sie keinen speicherplatz das ist
kein problem so wie ich das verstanden habe du kannst view 3 mehr oder weniger
wie view 2 verwenden du kannst ein paar sachen zusätzlich nur in view 3 machen
also es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen sachen dass du nicht einfach
eins zu eins dein view 2 projekt in drei laufen lassen
kannst aber die anpassung sollten sollten ziemlich minimal sein habe ich da gerade
templo s gelesen ja ja hast du schon mal was mit potman gemacht ja auf der
arbeit und potman ist mehr oder weniger eins zu eins kommando zeilen kompatibel
zu docker also wenn du docker machst kannst du potman machen und umgedreht
nur dass potman glaubt ein paar dinge mehr kann aber ehrlich gesagt weiß ich
gar nicht was potman mehr kann als docker
aber auf der arbeit bei uns stehen sie voll auf potman die ganzen container
gurus bei uns auf der arbeit die mögen docker nicht so können einem zwar nicht
so genau erklären warum aber die finden potman viel geiler letztendlich ist es
auch vollkommen wurscht also das wichtige an docker ist das format vom
docker feil und diese die ganze infras die geht dieses ganze ökosystem drum
herum ob das jetzt docker ist mit dem man was
startet irgendwelche kupanete sachen potman ist es vollkommen egal also docker
könnte eigentlich von heute auf morgen verschwinden und es wird alles so
weiterlaufen wie bisher
was bei hetsen erreicht ein kor nicht was echt nicht zauerei anzahle support ticket
ist raus ja das gucken wir uns einmal in den nächsten streams an da bin ich mal
gespannt drauf
da habe ich ja die übelste abneigung dagegen ging view x ich finde das total
überflüssig aber wahrscheinlich sind meine anwendung einfach nicht groß
genug react ich bin kein großartiger java script frontend man also mir reicht
dass ich mit view gs ganz gut zurecht kommen react muss ich mir da nicht auch
noch geben react werde ich mir irgendwann mal geben sollte es was sollte
was existieren was ich mit view gs nicht gescheit umsetzen kann was ich
unbedingt machen will
was connect frontend to database without backend das ist je nach technischen
problem ist keine kraft ql geschichte es gibt auch mittlerweile sogar schon für
postgres fertige fertige kraft ql plugins die dann quasi direkt eine
datenbank über kraft ql zur verfügung stellen also wenn man wirklich keinerlei
logik im backend braucht geht das auch schon ganz gut oder man nimmt so was wie
firebase so dass wir uns auf jeden fall angucken da bin ich echt gespannt
man muss man muss den auch mal zugute halten also den ihre update politik ist
wirklich ganz ganz ganz also umgänglich ja also nicht so wie andere nicht so nicht
so wie gtk und gnome wo alle alle monat mal was bricht die geben sich wirklich
mühe
man darf nicht vergessen das ist ja aus dem ein mann projekt entstanden
mittlerweile klar mittlerweile nicht mittlerweile sind mehr logisch aber der
typ ist schon big brain ich frage mich ob der typ wirklich avenue heißt oder ob
der den einfachen sonst in chinesischen namen hat oder hat sich einen coolen
englischen namen gegeben weil avenue das ist so irgendwie wie was heißt das
übersetzt die straße doch oder heißt es nicht so was wie straße avenue
aber der ist big brain der typ massive massive brain alle so was in der
richtung aber ja genau also was trennen der sonst noch nicht aufgetaucht hat
einmal one fuss twint ich soll tensor flow essen nur wenn es schmeckt warum nicht windows
was zum teufel ist das
klingt irgendwie nicht so vertrauenserweckend oder irgendwie
klingt das nicht so vertrauenserweckend ich weiß zwar nicht so genau was es ist
wenn ich irgendwas von truja na go shadow sock sonst was klingt irgendwie nicht
vertrauenserweckend ich weiß nicht was es ist aber es klingt nicht vertrauenserweckend
erstmal alles ausführen genau linux command auch schon wieder auf chinesisch
das ist manpage viewer für linux ach das in chinesische manpages ja das ist cool also
für mich bringt das nix aber ich glaube halt dass die dass der support und die
translations da halt ziemlich schlecht sind das sind quasi chinesische manpages
mit beispielen oder sowas ja nicht übel exzellent sebaro so muss das sein macht
der typ nicht youtube videos der name kommt mir bekannt vor macht er nicht
c++ youtube videos ich glaube von ihm habe ich schon das ein oder andere geguckt das
kommt mir echt bekannt vor ja ja ja ja den kenne ich
irgendwie ziemlich langweilig was es da die woche gibt nicht so spannend
das haben wir uns das kennen wir schon was ist das mittlerweile kann man sich
auch absolut nichts mehr ableiten aus namen von irgendwelchen services der
streamt doch auch ja kann sein
das ist so was wie no dread das ist so was wie no dread ohne no dread würde ich
mal sagen dass das ist das ist cool das gefällt mir
so schon mal book machen quasi no no no dread in in type script das verstehe
ich nicht die leute die sich immer fertige editor konfig holen es gibt kaum
was persönlicheres als ich wie so eine editor konfig also wenn man so was wie
customize diese ganzen riesen configs die quasi schon vorkonfiguriert mit
30 milliarden sachen kommen wo man gar nicht genau weiß was drinne ist
geschweige wie man es bedient finde ich total übertrieben
das besteht aus 30 milliarden zeilen da weißt du gar nicht was in einem editor überhaupt
läuft das wollte ich auch mal irgendwann ausprobieren vms auf ios
ok also leute schön dass ihr dabei wart ich gehe jetzt was essen ich habe
übelst hunger software so was mal als fazit kann ich
empfehlen gefällt mir haben wir selten im stream gehabt dass mich was so direkt
überzeugt aber fand ich gut time limit kann man auch aufheben also ich rede
jetzt hier von dings web das was heute ausprobiert haben also davon finde ich
gut gefällt mir nice um nicht zu sagen man auf discord nachher ja mach ich gucke
jetzt gucke jetzt gleich rein also heute macht es gut bis zum nächsten mal ich
hau ab bis mal gucken die tage mal gucken wie das mit arbeiten wird die
woche morgen muss ich wieder hin allerdings vielleicht geht dann ja auch
remote geschichten wieder und ich kann ganz normal homeoffice machen und mal
gucken wie das wie das wird also bis denn macht's gut
zu